what advice would you give to
16-year-old Cody who maybe she's she's
got $1,000 through mowing the lawn and
through tutoring maths or something and
she's got $1,000 and she's like I want
to invest this ,000 how would you
approach that conversation with your
young younger self well I'll tell you
what I tell my cousins now who are right
about that age so to my 16 18y old
cousins I say take the big risk now
while you have no responsibility the
more responsibility you get the scarier
the risk becomes when you have kids when
you have a mortgage when you have a big
paycheck that you could lose it's scary
to go start a business to think about
buying a business to think about being
the operator in a business um but when
you're young you should take all the
risk hum possible because failure
doesn't really matter when you're young
um I don't think you should take $1,000
doar and invest it in anything when
you're young unless you're investing it
in yourself or you're investing it in a
big risk likey trying to potentially
turn $1,000 into a $100,000 business
purchase interesting but not Bitcoin or
n not bit no no no no I mean there's uh
in in investing we say um we say that
those people are speculators not
investors and there's a whole generation
of people that have been taught
speculation not investing anytime you
have the last man fallacy which is that
the person who comes in next that you're
going to sell to is the one is the dumb
one that's going to be holding the bag
you should know that should run away
from that because you're the last man we
don't want to be a nation of people who
are trying to kind of dupe people into
being the next person to buy it at a
higher valuation than we did we want to
have assets that are so good that you
think like Warren Buffett and you want
to hold them for 30 years you have to
pry that business out of my cold dead
hands because it's a great business and
I think because we had that fast money
run of nfts and Bitcoin and stocks
people get confused and you know the
other thing that's that's so true is
really good Finance people who trade
stocks have something called a black box
they don't even tell their salespeople
that go and rep their product what's
inside of their algorithms it's firewal
you can't see inside why because I would
never tell somebody my unfair advantage
that everybody else could go replicate
immediately if trading is the way that I
make money so anybody that teaches
trading online is totally full of it in
my opinion because if they had great
secrets they would never share them
they' just pile as much money as humanly
possible into it and buy a bunch of
Bentley um and so I'm really cautious on
speculators and I'm really bullish on
ownership so how might said 16-year-old
or said cousin actually invest that
,000 you invested in yourself I think
you need to learn at that point you have
to learn then you increase your earnings
then you invest no 16 yearold should be
taking their thousand bucks and putting
in the S&P in my opinion they will make
so much more money by taking that, bucks
and going and learning how to create a
bunch of YouTube videos or going and
learning how to buy businesses or going
and learning how to talk to people and
negotiate whatever the case may be I
would take the thousand bucks and I
would consider it your little MBA money
and I think spend like that until you
can start putting you can do the S&P 500
putting 10% of your savings in I've done
that for a long long time but that won't
make you rich uh it'll just potentially
beat inflation hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
CLI then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye-bye